[Music]
it was a crackerjack
of a number monday night brought an
explosive penultimate episode to the
25th season of Dancing with the Stars
property brother drew Scott was sent
home in an emotional elimination and the
critical freestyle dances were the
competitors swung songs to voters Witney
Carson and Frankie Muniz brought tension
and drama I'm really happy you made this
choice because I feel that you of all
have made the most emotional journey
Jordan Fisher and Lindsey Arnold gave
sparkle and pizzazz to get a perfect
score a shuttle toast topic number and
Lindsey Stirling and Mark Ballas
embodied Lindsey's violinist vibes in
more ways than one mark played her and
she played for all of your incredible
uniqueness I mean that was you this is
becoming the war on the floor because
I'm so excited about tomorrow evening
because I have no clues gonna win it
just become a fantastic on the people so
who are you rooting for let us know on
ET Facebook page
[Music]
you
[Music]